[Music]
HTC vive oculus rift and PlayStation VR
brought us virtual reality gaming back
in 2016 while software has matured at a
steady pace over the last two years VR
Hardware has remained the same for the
most part until now strapping on the
ergonomically refined HTC vive pro opens
your eyes to a perceptible step forward
and visual fidelity for vr gaming
unfortunately these enhancements come at
a hefty price that make it a product
reserved for the most demanding VR
enthusiasts what makes the vive pro so
noteworthy is the higher resolution of
its dual oled displays going from the
combined resolution of 2160 by 1200 on
the original HMD to 2880 by 1600 on the
vive pro significantly refines the
visual quality of any vr game the simple
bump and resolution translate to a much
sharper image small details like foliage
vegetation and tree leaves look like
fitting pieces to a graphical puzzle
rather than fuzzy textures that fill up
a space which was immediately noticeable
in skyrim vr and when a game environment
heavily relies on a number of these
objects to create a more lively and lush
world the absence of jaggies is both
immediately apparent and much
appreciated even the barren wasteland of
fallout vr benefits from the resolution
bump as building interiors and abandoned
towns felt a little bit less artificial
by swapping between the original vibe
HMV and the vive pro multiple times in
different scenarios for each game we
played the improvement was evident in
game text is also much more clear
navigating menus and reading prompts is
significantly easier as you spend less
time trying to get the right focus on
text in virtual reality by nature of VR
projecting images so close to your eyes
graphical blemishes come to the
forefront so for the vive pro to reduce
aliasing to great effect alleviate
similar flaws again these enhancements
are due to the increased resolution
don't expect better textures lighting or
character models of course that's not
what the vive pro is here for now a
higher resolution isn't without its
drawbacks though like with any game
increasing resolution is going to demand
more performance from your PC with vive
it's absolutely crucial to maintain the
90 frames per second that the 90 Hertz
displays offer and because of this HTC
raised the minimum and
recommended PC specs to use the vibe Pro
when it comes to your GPU
you'll need at least a GTX 1060 or RX
480
but the recommendation for an optimal
experience is either gtx 970 or RX vega
56 while we spent most of our time on
the vive pro using a system equipped
with the top-end gtx 980ti
we tested the new hmd with a 6 gigabytes
1060 to make sure the minimum specs is
enough for games like fallout 4 VR sadly
even with the graphics settings turned
down we often had missed frames
throughout our time playing it monitored
via steams display frame timings we
didn't have this issue with skyrim VR on
medium settings on the native resolution
raw data ran just fine with a few miss
frames on rare occasions and didn't
compromise the experience but you should
really have the recommended specs or
higher to get the most out of the vive
Pro a comfortable frame rate is one
thing physical comfort is another and
the vive pro stock head strap is on
point with a form-fitting face pad
around the HMD and dense foam on the
back of the strap the vive pro provides
enough comfort for long sessions also
it's seamless design has the head strap
moving as one piece the top has an
adjustable velcro strap while the back
consists of an easy-to-use dial that
loosens and tightens the whole thing now
only does the design make it simple to
put on and take off but it provides
impressive weight distribution no longer
does HTC's headset have that nagging
front heavy feel in addition to the
impressive comfort the head strap comes
with built-in on ear headphones these
don't exactly have the clarity of
high-grade audio equipment but they pack
enough thumping bass and there's minimal
distortion for high and mid frequencies
accurate positional audio is also a
highlight which is a necessity for the
VR experience one drawback is that the
headphones won't sit perfectly flush on
everyone's ears and can compromise sound
isolation now one of the most
intimidating factors with VR is the cost
of entry price drops from all the
leading platforms have certainly lowered
the barrier but unfortunately the vive
pro abandons this trend entirely for 800
bucks you're only getting the upgraded
HMD with the new breakout box that's it
the vibe Pro does not come with the vive
controllers or the two required base
station sensors those who have yet to
hop on the vive eco system will be
shelling out a pretty penny for the
necessary equipment
this essentially posits the vive pro
solely as an up
great for those who already have the
original headset even then the price tag
is a lot to ask
with the vive pro HTC is raising the bar
for vr gaming headsets the benefits of
its higher resolution are undeniable
along with an improved head strap for
better comfort and weight distribution
it seems the vibe Pro is a clear win for
HTC however the high price may make it
cost prohibitive for VR newcomers
especially because of the incomplete
package this is very much for the VR
enthusiast with a high-end PC who wants
the latest and greatest Hardware
regardless of the price tag it's further
enforced by the fact that the minimum
specs won't cut it for more demanding
games if you don't fall into this
category there isn't enough to warrant a
vive pro as it stands as great as the
vive pro is you won't miss out on any
games or functions that you don't
already get with the original 5
[Music]